the upcoming series Cobra Kai based on
characters from The Karate Kid films so
that launches may 2nd on YouTube read
and also you got a guest appearance on
Kevin can wait with Kevin James doing
that as well so so ralph joins us here
what's the reaction on the street if we
walked out right now mm-hmm
within five blocks what am i hearing
well reaction what for the new show no
just you just me just you get out of my
way
I think the reaction is you know you've
been around I've been around long enough
in different different areas so I get
you know I'll get a nice broad spectrum
of Ages I get kids that parents made
them watch some of my movies or kids
that read The Outsiders see that film
yeah you know I'll get the stay gold
Ponyboy shoutouts oh I'll get the you
know paint the fence
no you know I'll get the wax on I'll get
the get him a body bags and all that
stuff that you guys probably open or
open your show with oh yes we've been
known to do that but usually usually a
pretty warm and usually a pretty warm
embrace but it's a compliment that
they're saying it yes I know yes I know
you get tired of it or you know how do I
respond to the 97,000 time that somebody
agent I'm doing the crane I didn't feel
that it's they're the first ones that
came up with it yeah I think I'll say
this much you know now as I get as I get
older or shall I say as I look younger
or try to I embrace it more and more
because he sign up for that and the
concept that say the curry speaking of
The Karate Kid in all this with the
Cobra Kai series coming out the fact
that it's 34 years ago and people still
have an opinion on it and want to talk
about it or make videos about you know
was the kick the crane kick an illegal
move and should you know is John justice
for Johnny or is it you know without
Miyagi is he really anything
and you know he was my he was my
inspiration and the fact that that is a
relevant conversation who would not sign
up for that 34 years later no mr. Miyagi
is Belichick right and Danielson is Tom
Brady Tom Brady have you heard that
analogy no and I enjoy it and I'm
married to a model now and though no I'm
married to the greatest woman would you
have been anything without mr. Miyagi
would Daniel Larusso yeah rothmeyer
would would Daniel Larusso um that's a
great question because we could all use
our little human Yoda to guide us
through adolescence and life I think
what Daniel Larusso has has become in
those films and now what happens to him
in Cobra Kai it's it's the I would say
he is not the he's a better a far better
man husband father because of the myagi
influence and that's part of the arc in
Cobra Kai when we first meet Daniel
Larusso thirty years later he has that
void in his life me ah he's been gone
for eight years martial arts is not
quite in his life anymore he's got a
great family successful car he's the
auto king of the San Fernando Valley
everything looks fantastic but as Miyagi
would say not everything is that seem
but Johnny is in this - Johnny is in
this - William Zabka brings Johnny
Lawrence I mean the concept for the show
it's a rivalry series these guys have
not seen each other since the infamous
crane kick and Johnny Lawrence has lived
every day that that crane kick - Johnny
Lawrence is probably the best thing that
happened to him in the last 30 years
where larusso's life has gotten quite
good and he's been quite successful and
as a wonderful marriage and all this and
and and so it's the juxtaposed life a
lifetime after 30 years daniel has moved
on and Johnny's lives every day in that
and there's you should own a piece of
you yes he totally wants a piece of it
he wants to he wants but what he
basically does is he opens the Cobra Kai
dojo which Larusso is not over my dead
body this is never needed flashbacks um
- Daniel getting his ass kicked over and
over again and he can't allow this to
come into the community and and so they
rub each other there they each other's
kryptonite they rub each other the wrong
the wrong way and and therein lies some
of the humor and the fact that you have
these guys in their 50s who still have
this high school rivalry you know and
then there's a whole new next generation
he's great high school the high school
world that hopefully will make this show
relevant to today's audience as well as
the nostalgia and-and-and have tipping
to to what we all grew up with
what was that script like when you first
saw Crotty kid what do you think I
thought it was kind of corny I thought
it was and and at that time I was pretty
young and just coming into it so it
wasn't like I was a seasoned veteran of
now you were done the outside on the
outsiders yes okay so I you know and a
few things before that but the outsiders
was sort of the big break and then
Karate Kid took it to another another
level I thought it was I thought that
the Miyagi Daniel relationship was and
it's interesting they always spoke about
Toshiro Mifune or someone some great a
Kurosawa cover saw is a kind of Japanese
actor coming in that told me a big fence
you know so there's a whole other thing
and when Pat Morita came in the room and
and was perfect in every possible way
that that chemistry was just spectacular
don't you up against for that role um
Charlie Sheen was around Downey jr. was
around I think they found me early they
found me early New York I read with John
avildsen
who just passed away recently sad you
know so some of these guys are not
seeing this resurgence now but I read
with John that video of me reading with
John is on you too you could see that on
YouTube my first cold reading and Pat's
first cold reading separately and he
sort of edited them together it's really
fascinating because it's basically they
handed me the script I read the scene
with the director and you could watch
that on YouTube and you see that kid
like you see the role it's not like okay
then we had to take it here
when did your life change with that
movie when the
soon after the new city right away it
was a sleeper hit but it was the talked
about you know going to a mall on a
Saturday became less of a smart thing to
do
yeah you know I mean that was the
biggest thing I noticed when I could
just go to the mall and hang out on a
Saturday and listen two weeks later I
went to the mall and it was no fun being
it the babies just you know it was
another thing it was fun at the onset
and then it became you know
did you realize Elisabeth Shue was gonna
turn into a Elisabeth Shue you never
know that you know you never know that
you're working with someone who's gonna
be nominated for an Oscar for leaving
Las Vegas I mean you just don't you just
don't know that you didn't know I didn't
know Pat Morita was gonna be nominated
for an Oscar for mr. Miyagi it's you
know when we were doing it it felt great
crazy and it's just wonderful and and
what do you have for the movie would you
say besides the trophy I have the
headband which I just brought on to the
Tonight Show and Jimmy Fallon this month
yeah last week you put it on I put it on
I did I went all-in
it was fun and he was a he was great he
was great we had a great time and I have
the 47 Ford convertible I have the wax
on wax off car yeah so I just I just
ordered all this stuff that's great oh
good thing I have a can of tuna fish
from my cousin Vinnie that's all I got I
sold a can of tuna
it's I'm not gonna open that can of tuna
since that was in 1992 The Outsiders I
have my sneakers and a leather jacket it
was a denim denim jacket did you have
like Chuck Taylor converse what were
your che were they were converse they
were coming soon yeah low-cut yep
did you know my cousin Vinnie like you
read that script right cuz you don't get
the Jesse lines
dad no I didn't I I was the my cousin
Vinnie was funny on the page funnier on
this whole world that was that was one
of the most well crafted calm American
comedy scripts as far as setups payoff
and all every setup paid off better than
you you knew it was coming and it was
even better you know but people didn't
know Pesci was capable of being funny
like right Nate funny hahaha yes I mean
they just threw me a beach ball I know I
literally I know
and Marisa Marisa Tomei breakout just
spectacular
back tacular performs and all the other
you know Fred Gwynne and as that is his
last performance yeah he's Herman
Munster yes he was
yeah I remember Joe saying he cuz you
know he was at first Joe is like I don't
know if he's right I don't know you know
he's like Herman Munster I said I'm the
Karate Kid
nice guy just let it go he's perfect but
and and just just then holding them in
the same frame was hilarious you Utes
though the to you the two Utes you still
get done yeah all the time but that's
it's just so so great you know I did not
shoot the cleric I've actually signed
cans of tuna for people people have
brought me cans of tuna and they said
would you sign you know I shot the clerk
and I said only if I could put a
question mark after it because that's
one of the things when we shot that film
we went on and on they we shot that
scene because the studio wanted it to be
a question yet a statement it was like
the toughest acting exercise ever had to
say I shot the clerk you're kidding
right right and and so that was yeah
it's fun to reminisce about that yeah
you look at those Outsiders Karate Kid
but when you pause if I saw Karate Kid
or my cousin Vinnie mm-hmm like you're
going through the TV right and if you
see it right which one are you stopping
to watch of all of those just those two
that's a good one and my kids would say
my cousin Vinnie because they both they
they love that film what's their
reaction to Karate Kid in my cousin um
they they that was you know it's not
geek dad that was that guy before they
were born you know I I always joke about
my my son finding all the tiger beats
and teen beats that my mom saved and he
comes in and yells to my daughter and by
those names Julie goes Jew dad was huge
and we missed it you were a hot team
there was a time there was a time yeah
but I answering your question I guess
right now with the Cobra Kai stuff and
the resurgence of the the Karate Kid and
what that means to America in the world
I would probably stop to watch because I
don't want
watch it that often but there are
moments in that movie that I just think
are beautiful and and so if it's the
right moment I'll stop to watch see I
would have taken the house mr. Miyagi's
house right over the car the house an
interesting story the house after the
shooting the first movie the the studio
didn't have the wherewithal to say let's
purchase this house because when we went
back or to know after the second one the
house was gone so they had to rebuild a
house on the Warner Brothers ranch where
was the house it was somewhere in the
middle of the San Fernando Valley but
did they steal the whole house I knock
it down
I think they knocked it down I think
they didn't know about and we and so but
all this stuff and the one cool thing
about the Cobra Kai series is we that
stuff over the course of season one and
hopefully many seasons to come
we see those places is it a dark comedy
I don't know no it's it's a it's it's a
dramedy or I mean there are really
moments of heart soul nostalgia all this
stuff that that the Karate Kid had but
the humor it's a more contemporary humor
for irrelevant times more humour for
2018 it's the it's so it has kick-ass
fight scenes it has it has humor just
based on the fact that these guys in
their fifties will not let it go it just
was a kicky illegal though I don't think
it was listen look at the elbow to the
knee right before that I mean I know he
was der don't get me started I just I'd
like to know if karate experts commented
on this it just felt like it might have
been a little dirty
yeah well listen it's you were better
than that I was better than that yes I
think so it's the one move that he
taught me
yes I got one I got one superpower I
know you gotta use it do you like
playing a little darker role in the
deuce yeah you know cuz I think people
see you and like you have a great image
attached to you right now the Funny or
Die thing that is it giving back so on
eff off yeah that was my
still the gift that keeps on giving
that was when the remake was put
together we're coming out with this
remake III was I was trying to sell two
shows from behind one behind the camera
one in front of the camera and both of
them did not even move forward and I'm
sitting I said I cannot watch this
remake come out without doing something
yeah not that I was against the remake
Oh rooting against it it only helped the
legacy of the whole thing and so I went
to Todd Holland just great single camera
director who I've worked with and
developed with before and you know the
lines like I'm not chachi mf'er stuff I
had in my back pocket and and I said
let's do let's do something where it's
an intervention on me being way too good
a guy when my own kids are trying to
mess me up so I'd be relevant and he
loved it and we walked in the front of
your die and I said here's the title I
didn't even get the second third word
out and they're like where and when and
it was just when Funny or Die was just
obviously Will Ferrell didn't help with
not you know but the guys at Funny or
Die Mike Farrow who runs it over there
and they you know all the writers were
just like jumpin jumpin at the and I
think the you know I believe that the
Brock Meyer I know Hank is a fan of your
show yeah I think Brock Meyer just that
just broke that and I think one of the
one of the guys who worked on that came
on to punch up our did it change
Hollywood's image of you I don't um
probably not but I did I think I think I
I would say they I gained a decent
amount of respect for poking fun of
myself and what I think was a kind of
cool way on my terms
you know and but as far as the saying
boy let's now you know now let's make
him a you know a dirty action hero I
don't think that's you know I think
that's happening but but the reducers
this is great deuce is very dark and
it's fun to play a guy like that even
the role and and Kevin can wait was a
you know just a jerk as I said to Zappa
the other day why don't you tell me this
is awesome being a jackass this is
perfect I what do you think Zabka so
johnny is one of the great villains of
all time
yes this
embrace being a villain he doesn't look
at it that way and he does it's really
he's so wonderful in the Cobra Kai show
he really is because you see the
entrance into the show into the karate
kid' University in nineteen you know in
2018 is now through the eyes of Johnny
Lawrence from the point of that King
where his life has been you learn of his
backstory Larusso you have a decent
amount of his backstory and then it
becomes sort of a dual protagonists dual
antagonist theories with like I said
with the young young high school world
as part of it as well he you know his
theory it's like Miyagi would say right
all no such thing as bad student only
bad teacher so that's his theory he had
a bad teacher he came from a broken
family and but by opening Cobra Kai up
again and believing in the best defense
is more offense and you know strike
first and call me later
it's still a crooked kind of negative
type of martial eye so he believes in it
yet he's trying to help the nerds and
Geeks that society today has so so
pampered you know everybody gets a
trophy every 100 things so he's all
against that and that's kind of fun but
but but really you know comes from the
human side you have to when you create
characters he just can't be all bad or
all good and I'm sure he only he's
getting what one-line when people see
him I don't that's a question for you
know that's gonna change in about a week
good because this show really opens up
the world for both characters and and
you bought between the two and it's very
entertaining and an exciting and the
fans are gonna love that there there's
even shots in the show and flashbacks
that are scenes we shot in the movie
famous scenes from the movie and 84 that
are using different camera angles now
they went back to this phony that
Columbia archives and got footage and
that's so the Nerds are gonna have a
blast
with that he's Ralph Macchio and you'll
be able to see him in Cobra Kai it
launches may 2nd on YouTube red also
officer Haddix and HBO's the deuce
thanks for being a great sport and we
appreciate it when you send in the
picture of the trophy now the trophy is
in one of your kids room is in my son's
room right now
that's a [ __ ] roofie it's a big truck
it's a big trophy now that was not that
was not just sought you know South
Valley that was all that was all Volvo
and under-18 though I was under I never
want anything once they I played 18 for
27 years do you have any other trophies
do I have any trophies
I had them from Little League back that
I'm sure they're next to the box of
stuff that my mom gave but you kept that
one yeah that one I guess but we have to
put that in a safe place though don't
you have to put it like in the
Smithsonian listen from you has anybody
ever asked for that trophy
no no what one thing I've been asked for
a lot is I did this film called
crossroads and I played a guitar and I
had a yellow I kept the yellow
Telecaster and that has been a lot of
musicians that would love to have that
guitar but you couldn't really play the
guitar right no I think they can you do
you couldn't do anything karate was
that's not that's untrue that's untrue I
did what I did well is in the movie what
I didn't do well same thing in my 50s in
the Cobra Kai I loved man Cobra Kai may
2nd on YouTube readies Ralph Macchio for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on Direct TV or download the
Dan Patrick show apps
[Music]